you're if I may say so one of the
richest people in the world so you're a
good person ask does money buy happiness
no it's been shown that between once you
get over a basic level of income so that
you can take care of the pain then you
know you can health and whatever there's
no correlation between the level of
happiness that one has and the level of
money that one has they that would think
that has the highest correlation is
quality relationships with others
community if you look at surveys of
these things across all surveys and all
societies it's a sense of community and
per interpersonal relationships that is
not in any way correlated with money you
can go down to native tribes in you know
very poor places or you can go in all
different communities and so they have
the opportunity to have that I'm very
lucky in that I started with nothing so
I had the full range I can tell you I
you know I not having money but but and
then having quite a lot of money and I
you know I did that in the right order
I'll tell you started from nothing in
Long Island yeah and my dad was a jazz
musician but I but I had all really that
I needed because I had two parents who
loved me and took good care of me and I
went to a public school that was a good
public school and basically you know
that you don't need much more than that
in order to that's the equal opportunity
part anyway what I'm saying is no I
experienced the range and else and there
are many studies on the answer to your
question no money does not bring
happiness bring money gives you an
ability to make choices does it get in
the way in any way of forming those deep
meaningful relationships it can there
are lots of ways that it makes negative
that's one of them it could stand in the
way of that yes okay but I could almost
list the ways that it could stand it
could be a problem yeah what does it
I so if you can elaborate you mention a
bit of freedom at the most fundamental
level it doesn't take a whole lot but it
takes enough that you can take care of
your yourself and your family to be able
to learn do the basics of have the
relationships have healthcare the basics
of those types of things you know you
can cover the patients and then to have
maybe enough security but maybe not too
much security that's right yeah that you
essentially are okay okay that is that's
really good and you don't that's what a
that's what money will get you and
everything else is could go either way
well there's more there's more okay then
beyond that what it then starts to do
that's the most important thing yes but
beyond that what its Tensta much to do
is to help to make your dreams happen in
various ways okay so for example now I I
you know look at my case
it's a those dreams might not be just my
own dreams they're their impact on
others dreams okay so my own dreams
might be um I don't know I can pass
along these at my stage in life I could
press along these principles to you and
I can give those they or I could do
whatever I can go on an adventure I can
start a business I can do those other
things be productive I can self
actualize in ways that might be not
possible otherwise and so that's that's
my own belief and then in a dot and I
could also help others I mean this is
you know to the extent when you get
older and with time and whatever rarey
you start to feel connected spiritual
spirituality is what I'm referring to
you can start to have an effect on
others that's beneficial and so on gives
you the ability I could tell you that
people who are very wealthy who have
that a feel that they don't have enough
money Bill Gates will feel almost broke
because relative to the things he'd like
to accomplish and through the Gates
Foundation and things like that you know
oh my god he doesn't have enough money
to accomplish the things he wishes for
but those things are not you know
they're not the most fundamental things
so I think that people sometimes think
money has value money doesn't have value
the money is like you say just a medium
of exchange at a store all the well and
so what you have to say is what is it
that you're going to buy now there are
other people who get their gratification
in ways that are different from me but I
think in many cases that let's say
somebody who used money to have a status
symbol I what would I say or that's
probably unhealthy but then I don't know
somebody who says I love a great
gorgeous painting and it's going to cost
lots of money in my priorities mecan't
not can't get there but but that doesn't
mean I don't Who am I to judge others in
terms of let's say their element of the
freedom to
those things so it's a little bit
complicated but by and large that you
know that's my view on money and wealth
you